and stars all right I see stars Oh oh my
god hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Resident
Evil everything is blowing up we don't
have any time I think I don't know maybe
we do I have I'm gonna just I'm gonna
try not to die is the only strategy that
I have thus far let me actually I need
to reload this I don't even know if I
have time for this
here we go alright we're gonna put this
away we're gonna put this away because
we have an abundance of ammo for the
first time in forever this is gonna go
great and we have no shotguns so what's
even the point of having that none I say
let's do this baby I don't know where
we're going but we gotta save Claire our
next true love I suppose hello where the
Bell are we huh oh that's not good all
right oh no no no no no no nope
there we go I'm not even gonna worry
about toasting you directly because I
don't feel like it's nest no no no there
we go yeah that's what I thought hey how
you doing hey how you do good to see you
good to see you can see you and goodbye
here we go alright
uh-huh well thanks for the advanced
warning I don't need these these are
fine I guess there's any secret said I
need to get while I'm running away from
my life I have no idea hit me boss is
there a need to fight any slower I could
go down this ladder there's bullets
somewhere here oh there we go
handy-dandy that thick keep giving me so
many bullets why now why don't oh that's
why now oh okay come on this way yeah
yeah you're stupid in it yeah stupid
dumb that's what you are dumb no thank
you
dumb foolish silly and stupid
okay surprisingly this is going pretty
well
oh [ __ ] oh ah my head don't crush my
skull
oh [ __ ]
ow
yeah well I was close good thing it
didn't get me
just like the tyrant good thing he
didn't get me it was close but you'll
get me next time yeah I probably gotta
get going I forgot about that oh yeah
the whole blowing up thing that's that's
kind of important um where am I Oh oh
that's so nice
more bullets what is this a joint plug
okay oh okay let me just put these in
here real quick there we go and what was
that yeah okay about that I'm sure what
is this oh how convenient the joint plug
perfect Whangdoodle that easy-peasy
oh [ __ ] shouldn't have done that
usually want something self-destructs it
blows up after the countdown is done not
during oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
Oh Oh you're big oh my god you got
bigger why did you get bigger that did
what's unfair you you can't just get
bigger I have to like work out hard and
eat right you just get bigger that's
that's hardly know whatever you know
what you're you're no different than the
other guy all right yeah you're down
there you go that's it
I missed I missed all right the last one
I did miss all right let me hang out I
got to eat my Wheaties here real quick
how it really hurts that you really kind
of hurt you kind of suck ah that was
poor timing all right the best I could
do G sums oh my goodness this is hardly
fair
good thing I eat my Wheaties you'll
never get me now okay you would have
thought that that would have hit him and
not me oh my goodness okay my Wheaties
seems to not be doing nearly as much as
I had hoped
ah probably not holy [ __ ] oh you've got
a heart oh okay ah I see I see I see
well see now see how this seemed to be
unfair seem to be just a little unfair
there seemed to be some level of
unfairness to this I couldn't read that
clue well yeah if this is gonna be an
all-out brawl I'm gonna need all of my
goodies which apparently I don't have so
let me go ahead and get all these lovely
goodies that I got this whole time
I've been sitting on this [ __ ] and now
I'm not so I'm gonna get this get all my
handgun ammo I don't have I can't make
any more shot cuz I just used it all but
it's fine it's all good baby it's all
good I don't know why it's all good it's
all good let's do this I guess brain up
[ __ ] yeah roar roar roar I should have
gotten the mod for Matilda oh da don't
worry I didn't get out nearly enough
Wheaties did I nice heart stupid idiot
oh he heard what I said ow alright its
Wheaties time baby and I also got some
spray you know how good my spray is oh
yeah oh give me that hard oh don't give
me the heart ah ah you really suck you
know that you really you really do suck
did that hit yeah oh boy
you just you really suck I'll go in with
a knife I don't care I'll do it
yeah I can I can tell that yeah I can
tell it's not good oh [ __ ] what am I
supposed to do for that what am i what
am I supposed to do what no don't
cheapen my experience okay
Matilda got an upgrade Matilda's now in
burst mode because apparently that's
what we're gonna have to do and then I
think I gotta save my grenades for the
charge thing because I I don't know I
don't know man I don't know escapes get
by here we go let's do this alright it's
just gonna be a bull out of this it's
just gonna be a lot of this maybe you
shouldn't wear your heart on your sleeve
ow all right I haven't eaten my Wheaties
yet can you can you hold off on being a
douche
yeah I don't feel so good do it ah I
barely got away ah no no no no okay
listen
it's Wheaties time baby you killed my
girlfriend or something I don't know
maybe was that you I can't remember who
Wow
my face is too strong for your claw yeah
that's right I'm gonna save this bullet
for you Wow
too bad you can't penetrate my shield of
love maybe you shouldn't be cracking
your bones so much you start cracking
more jokes yeah okay all right well it's
so it's gonna be like that huh whatever
that's what I thought
ow my back is my strongest part you
should have known that huh
I'm almost out of bullets oh how
convenient you've activated my second
phase maybe oh yeah okay all right we'll
call it even yeah okay where'd this come
from
oh [ __ ] oh just put this right there no
my ow
excuse you hey how about you suck it
showed and eat a child in fact holy [ __ ]
yeah I guess we'll call it even
my love came for me that was all ADA let
me spray some on me a little bit there
we go it's good stuff
five minutes is so much time oh oh [ __ ]
well well no time like the present huh
huge dude you suck so much dick I'm so
mad you made me miss ready between you
[ __ ] God you suck uh
you suck so much oh god I'm so mad
all right
Wow
Wow that is some that was impressive I
am very impressed by that
my love my sweet I might have still
needed that also where'd this train come
from do I do I know where this train oh
hi well Wow we've all we only have been
we've only seen each other like for a
grand total of 20 it was I could have
finished this in the last episode I
could have I could have but I didn't but
that's okay because the story moves on
there's something in my eye and I'm
going to die all right so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna wait and see if there's
something at the end of the credits and
then Claire story dust begin it doth
begin it begins doth Li
it will doth begin that I sped on my
monitor but this part of the game it's
so good alright obviously was there
business
alright we're getting to the end of it I
think very much like movie credits which
is not what I'm used to
I mean I know I probably could have
skipped it and gotten to whatever I
would have seen anyway but now I'm here
okay any day now any any day now any all
right capcom hell yeah whoo capcom there
we go
hello that's not good what the hell that
was on the train that we were on but
still kind of wondering what those are
gotta be there I gotta be everybody yeah
probably because he found a save zeg
that's bad all the amount of deaths I
add was pretty incredible maybe this
next one I don't need to do with as many
saves because now I've got a better
understanding of what I do look at all
these costumes look at all this loot
look at what I've done and I've done so
much yes a waste of space I don't know
what that means I feel insulted by that
new game second run has been unlocked
selectively from story ending in certain
parts of the game are different in the
second run scenarios oh great huh Claire
jacket Wow look at her look at the
jiggly bag look at the jiggly butt bag
okay I'm not looking at her but who's
looking at the bag it's jiggly I don't
know why surgically look at this jiggly
bag all right
um ada look at the jiggly coat Marvin
branding oh look at him he's got nothing
jiggling on him except his life gee
adult what oh yeah I remember that okay
that's no good Oh gross don't don't do
that will hey buddy hey a little jiggly
too but not that jiggly okay super
tyrant yeah okay Louise you told me this
guy had this much beef hiding under his
coat now they made him bigger okay so
all that aside new games second-run play
through the second scenario from the
beginning that's what I'm going for
right isn't that what I'm going for new
games second run right click yes who's a
yes yes let's do this standard I could
do it hardcore but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna because I don't need it I don't
feel like it and I know how to do it I'm
gonna do standard again yes yes your ass
okay let's focus
yeah I'll be back in a sec fine Chris
why is everyone thinking to get in
trouble
uh-oh
[Applause]
I appreciate the accelerated nature of
it
[Applause]
oh hell yeah ya know to win it baby for
you to win it second Robin let's do this
[ __ ]
okay we'll never mind we're in man
either they really know what they're
doing when they made this or there's a
there's a different experience depending
on which one you start first yeah yeah
yeah okay okay three bullets letter from
best friend biking all the way to
Raccoon City just to see your brother
what the hell girl I don't know
Chris means a lot to you and yeah you
haven't been able to reach him for
months but you're nuts you know how many
perverts and [ __ ] are out there just
waiting for a hot young college student
to come along and take advantage of it's
not safe to travel alone but your mind's
made up
don't leave your bestest best friend
hanging love you okay that's a lot of
graves why are there graves here okay so
forget everything that you already know
about this game just expunge it from
your brain act as if this is a
completely new scenario because it is I
don't know anything that's going on
anywhere that's not a good sign ah
perfectly normal for a police station to
do that because I don't know anything
and this is going to be a very different
experience from what we're used to
that's the boarded-up area that's
supported up area I imagine that a lot
of these places are gonna overlap like
I'm gonna be running around the police
station when oh [ __ ] ah I'm gonna be
running around the police station when
oh that happened already okay well we're
already there
Wow that's hello buddy how are you doing
I don't have a flashlight I don't know
why I don't know why we're already over
there but apparently we're already over
there okay I want to double check my map
because I'm very bad about making sure
that I get everything okay I just want
to be very thorough about getting
everything and take this a lot slower
because I'm not nearly as tough as I
once was I don't have nearly enough
bullets I don't even have a knife so I
gotta be very careful about this Hey
look at this look at this cutting tool I
didn't get this for awhile before oh
we're here already Wow that's quick
Claire it's so nice to see you how are
you doing falling unfortunately no but
how are you doing
you know just surviving that's good yeah
I need luck with your brother now yeah
Claire don't lose hope I'm sure we're
gonna find him
yeah we didn't oh yeah we didn't oh yeah
yeah I only got three bullets and a bolt
cutters
let's get through this both of us
okay so I y-your little close for
comfort I'm gonna skate right by you
you're not gonna get me you're not gonna
kick me none of you are gonna get me
I didn't leave anything behind okay so I
got the bolt cutters and I gotta get in
there we didn't get Chris at all but I
imagine that we're gonna address that in
this scenario probably to snip to snub
good thing there were two pairs of those
all right we're in hello
Wow Oh oh boy
oh oh boy oh boy Wow we are wow we're
getting Wow okay well I don't need the
deluxe I don't need those okay so these
are two different ones a high-caliber
ones are not a high caliber but they're
both revolvers so that's interesting
okay this is doesn't help me in any
capacity this is 45 ammo large caliber
ammo okay so that's what we're gonna be
dealing with courtyard key dough kg
zooms can I put on the police uniform
maybe I don't know all right I'm gonna
put these in here until I have something
to do with them yeah I guess I guess
that'll be good enough that yes all
right
is that Chris Chris is that you oh no
that's Brad Vickers I guess that's it
all right back out we go why did you do
that
you son of a tit why are you there why
are you there don't make me I hip shoot
okay well that didn't seem any better
than any other bullet that I had before
okay what was even the point of that all
right well [ __ ] I'm oh wait a minute
oh that door I have the key now god damn
you're getting up okay well there was no
point in me doing that anyway you suck
you suck this is not high-caliber in any
way shape or form
okay that's oh boy alright okay well
that's good hey how you doing hey how
you doing let me see if I can unlock
this then I can actually find Leon right
just that easy
Leon duh maybe I should have tried to
open this oh boy yeah maybe I should
holy [ __ ] okay I'm out of here your dad
your guy can bolt cut this duh fill the
order of things happening doesn't make
sense to me but again I'm pushing it out
of my mind I already know the things
that have happened it have not happened
so I don't need to worry about taking
something from somebody else while
somebody else does something else to
somebody make sense probably I'll take
this thank you I don't have room I of
room I needs bag
I need bag valve died can't hold valve I
can't hold valve I can't hold valve okay
this move I don't know why is happening
what can I get through here no [ __ ] I
forgot there's up piss okay doesn't seem
like this nearly as many zombies as
there were last time so that's good what
is this
I have never went in here oh I don't
have space for this ah there we go
perfect sure yeah okay okay I need you
to what the hell oh my god that's slow
oh not a tan grenade oh my god that's
gonna hurt me real bad oh good god
that's so slow huh something tells me
there's gonna be them the more stressful
playthrough just because of the amount
of stuff that I gotta get through least
has given me all the high-caliber stuff
but I'm you know to be perfectly honest
say I feel like it's just the same so
let's stop panicking for two seconds
because I got a remember I think there's
a fuse in this room here
why how are you are you kidding me yeah
you stay down there's a fuse there was a
fuse somewhere in here this bullets over
there
there was a fuse wasn't there but
there's a valve now and I don't know
where the valve goes but it goes so I
need that valve I definitely need the
valve there we go first aid spray for
some reason still here but I don't think
I have room for it so there's got to be
someplace to use this valve somewhere
around here oh [ __ ] okay ah there we go
nope apparently not done apparently this
is open though scrap a paper oh that
doesn't help me at all why is this torn
out of that thing that wasn't that
wasn't torn out there's no way oh this
is weird
I'll fuse though no knife though I don't
have space for that [ __ ] alright maybe
now that I know maybe I can put this
here because I can drop this I can
discard anything with this mark okay
that that's what it said now that's what
I thought but I just didn't know okay
whenever I got that so very stressful
very stressful I don't like this very
stressful very stressful very stressful
okay
plants good no safe okay
we're just gonna save everything's gonna
be good we're just start the saves over
we're not gonna save nearly as much
but it's going good okay everybody pause
breathe it's all okay I know this is
jarring it's jarring for me too there's
a lot going on I don't know a lot of
what's happening but it's fine
everything's fine it seems to only be
getting me the big ammo so I'm gonna
stick with the quick-draw army gun and
the big ammo until I know otherwise I'm
gonna forego the flash grenades all the
fancy stuff I'm just gonna stick with
the very basic of what I need because I
don't have nearly enough space to deal
with it without consolidating things I
am NOT Leon anymore I don't have the
space I don't have the time I don't have
the extra bullets I don't have the extra
anything and to get what I need to get
okay check these get bullets yes please
get this get high-grade gunpowder to
these to make submachine gun called acid
Rao that sounds so cool that sounds rad
all right cool
I'm down for that what is oh my god
Claire gets the best [ __ ] holy [ __ ] okay
all right fine that's how it's gonna be
I guess that's how it's gonna be holy
crap all right I wish I had a flashlight
oh I do have a flashlight never mind all
right what do we got here
red ominous glow huh oh I can't go in
there okay so I got the fuse so that
means I can get out in the main area
I wonder if Marvin's still alive you
think Marvin's still alive I bet
Marvin's still alive that son of a [ __ ]
he's got a survival streak to him that
Marvin you know Marv Marv is just our
real servo oh god why are you now
whatever screw you okay that Marv is a
survivor there's something else in this
office worth grabbing why why I'll get
later now worried about it
baboom baboo ski Marv Marv Marv oh
you're not Marv
we're Marv go Oh Marv
ah [ __ ] Marv's all turned and stuff
Marv's turned hey well alright then oh
wait Ann stop stop I need you to stop
for real sick there's there's something
here oh oh okay oh hey hey how you doing
Marv a good to see you Marv you take
care of Marv you take care notebook with
mythic missing page okay well I already
know I have the missing page I don't
know if I need to do that do I need to
do that puzzle again then do I really
got to do that puzzle again yeah I
probably do lazy son of a [ __ ] Leon
he'd never do I can't I can't read that
okay all right I'm gonna just Marv Marv
no no come on
lady god damn it
yeah you go all the way down the stairs
stupid I can't go that way
oh just a bunch of people trying my
patience over and over again just a
bunch of people trying my patience
non-stop that's all I'm getting
I am limping up a storm I need some
spray real bad hello ah good perfect for
spray you think this is gonna be the
same I don't remember what it was anyway
all right so this is a dead end
oh this used to be a museum oh that
makes sense
that explains Oh goddamnit that explains
that explains a lot yeah that explains a
lot okay you gonna get shot
oh there you go there you go there you
go critical strike okay so I gotta get
out of here I'm gonna go through the
entryway down there
hi Marv hey how you doing good to see
you good to see you guys
you stay fresh you stay fun you stay
free stay the hell away from me okay
spray that's good I like spray I'm going
to recover my health and I'm going to oh
there's no there's no bucket here
apparently for some reason ooh what fun
I'm just going I'm just going and I'm
gone great wonderful thank you for that
that was a very invigorating experience
okay thank you all of you for it just
such wonderful wonderful people very
warm and inviting I already know what
happened here okay police station map
good great there's got to be something
else in there I see bullets I see France
I see it as Underpants for anyone they
didn't know once the room stops being
red that means that there's nothing else
left in the room to get hopefully anyway
you're still there there's
way in hell you're still there trying to
get a snack I don't believe it
I don't believe it at all I don't even
remotely believe it I don't believe it
none
I believe it's zero I believe that that
is hilarious you are just adorable
you're so cute
I forgot something and I've ever met I
just remember now I remember seeing
something in another room and I didn't
grab it I just had a vision of that I
just had the vision of that oh no oh no
and you you don't even have your [ __ ]
alright well I can't get you and I can't
get you I can get you not that that's
gonna do me any good grenade launcher
that's oh [ __ ]
okay well let's get 109 come on you 109
and then 106 okay got those and I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go now I'm gonna go
thank you
a real real oh yeah real real Rory he's
so Rory you're so Rory never known
anyone so Rory
oh [ __ ] god dammit why - ah why not
today
I need that knife back though I'm gonna
need that back I'm gonna need that back
can I have that back please can you
please come out this way okay all right
well this ain't good
oh [ __ ] I'll get that later all right
what are we had here gunpowder perfect
yes please
uses a gunpowder I'm aware except it's
different because now there's submachine
gun and acid rounds and I don't know
what the acid rounds mean but that
sounds rad as hell I don't remember what
these are ya might know you don't have
the one you don't have one looking for
okay operation blah blah blah rookies
first assignment okay is there the same
as it was before it should be the same
right Marvin Marvin Rita see Marvin Rita
and I don't remember what it was gee
yeah you can do it damn it
thank you I need that whoa whoa whoa hey
don't run why are you going that way
okay we got Neal Eliot oh my god okay
I'm gonna just do this I'm gonna open
this up Ned all right sure yeah
perfect speed loader that's dot for the
gut that's for the other gun [ __ ] okay I
can't go this way anyway
well my knife is gone that's okay I
didn't need it anyway
can't go in there oh but I can't go down
there okay this is going great I feel
good about this
this seems do it do what do it do it
that's all I heard okay perfect perfect
it's like they making it harder on me
because they know I've dealt with it
before which I appreciate and don't
appreciate in equal measures so this SLS
will go with combined with this now am I
mistaken in that no I don't have the
bullets for this why did it give me this
I don't have these bullets okay I
already know about this that's the same
okay I've got two full mixers I've got
flame rounds I've got gunpowder I'm
gonna hold on to the Gunpowder yeah this
is okay I'm not gonna make anything
until I know I need it so I'm not gonna
worry about anything anywhere I'm so
good bye who's here there was somebody
here oh there you are oh [ __ ] perfect
okay that doesn't sound good
what's going on oh [ __ ]
good god [ __ ] oh my god why did I do
that
I wasted those bullets real bad don't
panic never panic cool under fire
there we go boom gone good you're good
good good good good good good good very
good very good very good for me and very
good for you I have what I need for this
so I'm just gonna go ahead and use it
very good are you still in here Oh
twitchy and whatever um I wonder if it's
the same wasn't a CIP holy [ __ ] it's the
same thing oh I gotta remember then that
that means the safes are the same I
don't remember what they were
ah [ __ ] I'm such an idiot I'm getting so
many flame rounds Jesus oh that means
they're the same a ruby box this isn't
supposed to be there or whatever it
doesn't matter
portable safe is not the portable safe
anymore all right let's go here then hey
buddy
man just a bunch of slum bows around
here all right get that okay hello
Lichter no I barely knew her more flame
rounds okay why just in case I'm gonna
go nice and slow here because you never
know what you're gonna see I were okay
nine-fold I'm getting a lot of [ __ ]
here okay
nine okay nine fifteen seven that's what
that was more flame rounds nice I guess
Oh submachine gun Claire I hope you get
this this place is crawling with
monsters and your brother's not here
just get out of here as soon as you can
I really hope you're safe oh I don't
remember writing that note at all I
think that's a lie perpetuated by the
game the government of the game yeah
jeez I'm full up now goddamn it well I
hope well there wasn't anything that I
actually needed to get first aid okay
ah but this okay whatever
all right let's move on scope oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa
why are you here you don't get to be
here you don't get to be here that's
just that's it you don't get to be here
it's a little too early for you it is
way too early for you you do not get to
be here I don't appreciate that and I
don't appreciate you oh I need to go get
the bag from the safe but I don't have
time for that
oh it's a one-way street now oh [ __ ]
please don't
nice very nice I'm very proud of myself
do I remember what this one was no I
don't I don't remember hey cool
daisuki I'm just gonna put that where I
can definitely put that just gonna
combine these two I know it's gonna look
at it real close um
I'm just gonna come back for it later I
can't I can't cuz if I don't go through
here now I I'm not gonna be able to get
out cuz I can't get it I can't I gotta
get it
ah [ __ ] oh I'm very extremely boned wait
no perfect hand [ __ ] hand gun ammo
that's not what I'm John it's not what I
wanted I that's not what I wanted I
thought it was gonna turn into Hyde
caliber gun but okay well I am just so
unbelievable uh don't do that to me
okay map yeah okay map good map map real
good I like map map good map good map
good I like map map real fast good you
know I can't pick this up can't do that
no room needed to go get bag but me not
get back because me not know what me
need okay I need a what's gonna happen
is this dude this dude he's gonna come
around he's gonna go somewhere where to
go okay seems like I missed him I missed
him he's gone he's gone so I need to go
back around I need to get that bag I
need to get the key and then I need to
get the hell out of here
in that order oh um oh god no that's not
it's the opposite of oh [ __ ] yeah I
thought you were somewhere else okay I
will go around you watch this move sick
move and miss me oh god I cut the
haymaker right in the face right in the
teeth that's not what I wanted okay
that's not what you want that's not what
you want to see it's never what you want
to see right haymaker right to the teeth
yes dad is that good for nobody there
all right but watch this dick move I'm
gonna get out here I'm gonna get this
god I'll get the jaw [ __ ] off oh boy
go out to eat this I guess okay that's
good that's good
all right so once I get this I can lose
them in the loop oh [ __ ] off
okay great no okay excuse me while I
just check my notes real quick okay nine
fifteen seven okay
easy-peasy nine fifteen seven done love
it love it love that love that that's
great I don't have any health oh [ __ ] me
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
I'm dead oh boy that's that you know you
asked not what you want to see that's
not you with that you don't want to see
that
that's my goobers that's my interior
goop
I need that that's my goop that's that's
the kind of goop that I need this is
freaking hard
oh I'm here why but now I know the code
it's 9:15 seven and if I remember that
then I can get what I need
most assuredly that's a weird sound hey
buddy
BAM baby hey lady
yeah you bastard yeah you bastard you
hear that you bastard okay
oh hey how you doing okay I don't think
this is gonna go any better oh [ __ ]
that's awesome I wish I could get like a
perfect shot again I feel like there's
got to be some place on the dome of a
Zombo that's just like instant heads
blow oh my god I'm a nail in these heads
blows can i yes my knife yes ya'll eat
okay get this now for only I could
remember everything else that would be
that would be the ideal okay let's go
back up because now we got what we need
to be able to carry on oh hey
here we go
I need to stop wasting so much ammo
hello ass man
goodbye ass man just gonna pretend I
never saw that and move on with my life
all right back over here into the stars
room Oh also benefit I won't have to
waste gunpowder on making stupid [ __ ]
now that I know there's nothing
licky over here I can just barge ahead
hey if I don't trigger him he doesn't go
anywhere so that's nice
I think he's coming I think I think
that's the footsteps I'm hearing are
yeah he's definitely still on the way
yeah he's oh yeah that that is the sound
of an angry man and I am probably the
source of that anger oh why did I not
reload yeah okay I'm going I am go I am
grabbed and I am going let's make this
happen baby
let's make it happen let's make it
happen captain - oh boy
do I have time no I don't have time okay
so there's that gunpowder let me hang on
let me double check what the Gunpowder
does now cuz it's different okay uh acid
rounds that sounds very important I'm
not gonna worry about it right now I'll
come back for it like everything I'm
gonna come back for it can I get this
nope goo ba out baby out demon all right
so now that I got that I've gotta find
another place where there's a safe zone
but it's like it's like this entire this
entire section of the game I've been on
the run
oh hi Marvin goddamnit Marvin I don't
want to shoot you Marvin Marvin I can't
die you have to follow some rules
everybody I can't shoot Marvin I can't I
won't I refuse you can't make me I'm a
man of principle Claire's a lady of
principle at least I can open this where
was there
oh that's not good those that's that's
not good uh it's it's not good okay well
he's a common I can shoot this guy no
problem are you no problem shooting this
guy you know what actually he's a yeah
Jesus
yeah Jesus I don't need your help here
Marvin you son of oh my god Marvin more
than you suck Marvin you suck so big Lee
oh my god Marvin you you suck now God
you all suck Marvin you're the worst I
hate you Marvin God why do I have to be
such a principled noble hearted man
oh I have such I have such lick my mouth
Oh God okay I have such stuff such
scruples my scruples are so girthy and
strong I'm the screwiest man that ever
did ever oh my god
my morals and my scruples are so big and
strong I have there's no human with
bigger scruples and or morals then I
Kabang Kubo can I please just hit my
target oh my god I waste bullets Oh
oh my god can I get in here now am i
safe am i safe and I am NOT safe okay
need to take this I'm not gonna just
give up and die because that's a GD
thing I am gonna save tho but I'm not
just gonna give up and die that'd be
stupid and dumb and I am neither of
those things
I have strong bones cuz I ate my
Wheaties all right so I can go around
where the tyrant was now so I can go
this way I don't know what good that's
gonna do me I don't know if that's any
good at all but that's gonna be some
kind of good maybe hopefully and I can
get some more of the stuff that was in
this office how much room I got a little
bit let me grab the the first aid spray
I'm gonna need that for certain I guess
I can grab this
okay diamond room don't have that but
this is now unlocked and this leads to
the library okay so what I can do is the
unicorn one do I have a scrap of paper
for the unicorn its people judgment
snake okay people judgment snake easy
got it right too badly on I'll never get
this I guess okay in the box okay in the
box
give me the box oh yeah what we got oh
oh that's handy okay that's good now yes
alright good I guess um I would go back
this way but I think that the tires
probably following maybe not maybe not
okay we might have a clear shot
I guess we're clear I guess we're clear
baby yeah we're clear okay we're clear
oddly enough we are clear
please tell me that lady guard has not
gotten up again okay good
boom okay Oh crown Firebird I was close
I was close crown Firebird okay crown
Firebird got it nailed it crown Firebird
easy what's left in here sir honestly
something luck that I didn't grab in
here
oh the locker perfect love it love it
stop the only two bullets but I still
love it that doesn't sound good
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay
a crown Firebird yay okay let's uh
ring-around-the-rosie god damn you
pocketful
[ __ ] you yeah go that's what I'm talking
about okay that happens more often these
days I'm gonna use this love that love
that love actually love that love
actually alright so next I'm gonna go up
I'm gonna unlock the other area and I'm
gonna try to see where that's gonna lead
me because I have what I need for that
so let's do that by Jesus see you around
the band have a good day go to hell
Oh also can I remember this one please
it was to something I know it was to oh
I don't remember okay why I don't
remember it's fine I didn't grab the
book I wanted the book
okay that's unnecessary but I'm in
trouble now oh boy
bingo Bongo I'm in trouble whoa oh well
you see there buckaroo nee um I don't
really have space for that but I'm
getting in anyway which is gonna be a
mistake soon oh whatever
okay I'm back here I've been here before
oh how did I miss that 50 that's a lot
of bullets
all right but either way I got a safe
space here we're done with this
apparently so we can put that away put
that there
save why not no going back and forth
with nice relaxing atmosphere for Claire
always stress always panic always moving
breakneck speed okay is there something
still in here apparently something in
here maybe oh hell yeah that's what I
needed all right I'm gonna cut across
the Marvin Marvin Marvin Marvin Marv
Marv you do not do that to a lady Marv
you do not do that to a lady Marvin what
if we talked about it is expressly not
that and not to a lady that's what we
have discussed oh [ __ ] oh sure okay um
all right this is gonna be real tight
cuz I need to get in that room and then
I need to grab the Rue book and the I'm
not gonna make it
I don't know why I'm even trying here I
go I'm trying this is a mistake well you
know what I'm here to make mistakes and
mistakes are what I'm supposed to make
combine that with that put that right in
the slam bam thank you ma'am
give me the Ruby I'm gonna put the Ruby
in the thing I'm gonna open up the box
I'm gonna have the stars thing
and then I'm gonna get the submachine
gun or the grenade launcher I forget
which and then I'm gonna blast your ass
into grass I'm guy let me get a closer
look at this that means little scream OH
blink and then combine this with this
that's that's peculiar
alright and stars alright I see stars Oh
oh my god no no no no no oh well this is
our go Joe [ __ ] huh
that's a problem ok I just please don't
please don't I've got places to be
things to see I don't know how I made it
out of there but I did oh no not like
this bar not like this Marv ok wait
which way am I going costumes costumes
what oh it's like classic it's like
classic classic what it was originally I
guess more more or less forget it for
now not what I was worried about I'm
worried about wait I forget where I'm
going because I have the stars I need to
go I can get there from I can cut
through the library okay I can cut
through the library to get to where I
need God I feel I'm trying to remember
and fast as I can everybody I've just
got a big old thing chasing me little
bit of a problem oh hey um I can cut
through here good thing I know this so
well Lichter flick don't ok stars pop
this bad boy open fruity poopy and
flippity poop and poop has been flipped
we flipped my poop we put the poop in
the thing we've shoved the poop in and
we open up the poop yeah give me give me
give me give me give me okay whatever
yeah it's great I love it it's my
favorite thing I don't have any ammo for
it right now
ah stars member that's Chris do I have
anything to say about that
barely it's Chris I don't know what to
tell you it's that sure is Chris
all right hundred percent Chris all
right I can turn this back off Kyle need
no more dine dine done did I get
everything I need a premier yes I did
okay let's go before he comes and gets
me house he's a-comin and he wants to
get me all right there's a map there did
I miss a map okay whatever there's
apparently maps there maybe I died last
time I thought I got that but I might
have died I might have definitely died
in fact I'm pretty sure I probably died
all right so we got that um what I need
to do is I need to why why why is this a
thing ah [ __ ] I didn't mean to go this
way um well I need to get what I need is
my Baba there's gunpowder in there if
that be nice to get maybe I should go
get that lictors in here I don't think
so no okay so I'm gonna go get the
Gunpowder oh that didn't sound good go
this way no holy [ __ ] that is going well
for me where are those steps come from
No ah [ __ ] okay well cuttin through here
then there we go
I didn't mean to cut through there but
apparently I was cutting through there
that's that's how this goes okay I need
to go get those ammo down here grab this
just a little bit probably yep just a
little bit but now I can get myself some
sweet Oh some sweet delicious so machine
gun ammo as soon as I get that what do I
have and what do I need I've got the
Stars I need to put that away because
I'm not gonna need it for a long time
I've got Farrell's I've got ammo things
I've got flame rounds I've got some
machine gonna I left that in there again
god damnit where is the final key
medallion thingamabob there's one more
medallion thingamabob where is that
that's what I got to find
oh is it in the art room I think it
might be in the art room I think it
might actually be in the art room but I
was so fast in and
there that I didn't have time to
actually do it I might be in the art
room
the grad ha no goddamnit
[ __ ] criminy you sack of [ __ ] I hate
you so much
Oh why are you I forgotten you were here
oh my god did I really I don't even have
them I don't even have this submachine
gun anymore I didn't grab this is pre
god [ __ ] dammit god this is before I
even did the sick manoeuvre with the
Ruby oh god I'm so whoa this is a dis
unbelievable okay let's try this again
we got to make this run like nobody's
business I guess
[ __ ] I'll be back ah that's what I
missed in here okay please don't be
Jesus please don't be oh no oh no oh no
oh why god only that that's unnecessary
and rude frankly very rude can you crack
your neck a few times that'd be really
great okay thank you goodbye I'm gonna
go get a submachine gun now and you're
not gonna stop me
this is brutal
okay here we go examine and push put in
great put on great put this in my
inventory great read this letter from my
brother great all that's in here is good
and great and take this back great and
let's go great
okay I've got two bullets and then some
submachine gun ammo and I've got some
gunpowder in my inventory that I can use
I'm gonna go save first I'm gonna go
save and then we're gonna get out of
here oh my god
hello face down ass up zombie you are
just oh you always put a smile on my
face whenever I see you
alright go here safe good guess gone yes
I'm alive and I'm saved okay so we're
gonna go here we're gonna get this
high-grade gunpowder we're gonna turn it
into there well that's a lot I like that
that's a lot
then we've got plenty of this ammo I'm
gonna store this I don't eat it for now
the weapon Locker is right around the
corner let me go get that then I've got
a grenade launcher I don't have the
necessary keypads to be able to get the
other thing in here not here here here
I'm gonna go get this but if I have a
grenade launcher I feel like that is
gonna put me on equal footing finally
with where I might have been with Leon
open please thank you gift Oh Papa give
to mama
give to mama all right perfect okay I
love it it only takes up one spot I love
it we are in it to win it okay hi Marv
were you there the whole time how did I
miss you okay well it doesn't matter
okay so I know that the lady statue for
the emblem is in the c4 area the c4 area
so I need to get c4 before I'm able to
actually do that so in order to do that
to get c4 that was available in the
little area but to do that I need to get
the key I need to get a key to get in
the records room which was the green key
to get no not that one the bolt cutters
I have the bolt cutters I know where to
go for that that's fine okay I know
where to go I think
uh-oh oh you sack of [ __ ]
there you go you're dead you're done
you're done okay you're done
it's only holds 24 bullets so I need to
go around here I could have done this
before but I didn't do it I don't know
why I could have done this so long ago
but I forgot you needed a key when in
fact you just needed a bolt cutter ah
perfect done has this done okay I'm
gonna just discard that cuz I can't I
don't eat it anymore okay this put that
there okay and then capi already knew
that one combine that with a battery
once I go back and get the battery which
I don't have right now that there are
anything else in here no we're good all
right let's get at it
hmm this game is a lot harder when
you've got someone like the big [ __ ]
breathing down your neck the whole time
all right let's go up to the bomb place
let's blow that [ __ ] up and let's get
either eff out because I am tired of
being the third wheel in a pattern of
Ditka tree and I don't want to deal with
that and I wish that I could remember
what the codes were but I don't because
I'm dumb that [ __ ] criminy you sack
of [ __ ] you piece of poop my god I feel
like you've meant that elixir is
probably gonna come by but I've got a
face full of [ __ ] for it when it do use
that let's go baby
whoo I'll take some of that yeah it's
good stuff
perfect no I don't know though that
didn't sound good Ram Hart bird okay got
it don't I will [ __ ] you up with a
[ __ ] where are you no oh no okay this
is fine
I'm pretty sure there's a liquor in here
somewhere and that's okay I just need to
get this guy to wrap around here
so that I can move this shelf with no
problem ah just be louder why don't you
just be loud it's a little louder you
know loud loud is what you want in these
situations okay we're out okay who wants
a face full of grenade okay that's what
I've got to offer you all here at a
supreme discount from what it typically
would be MSRP okay I'm out of here
I'm out I'm out I'm out I'm out please
don't be immediately there immediately
there god damn it oh my god I'm not
dying I'm not dying for you I'm not
dying for anybody here I'm not dying not
for you not for anybody you come through
that door
you do it you come through anybody else
want it yeah you tussle with my muscle
I'll tussle with your muscle you tussle
with my muscle now you don't get me not
my muscle no means no I'm gonna put this
in the statue I'm gonna go down there
and Marv is really gonna be proud of me
Marv you proud of me you're not Marv the
hell are you you're not Marv I put it in
I put it in and I'm gonna go down and
that's all there is to it I'm going I'm
going
goodbye farewell goodbye goodbye and
farewell does it lock behind me I sure
hope so my god this is the most
stressful anything I've ever seen
okay I've got a lot of gunpowder but I'm
just really hesitant to use it yet
because I don't want to so I'm not gonna
and that's still open and I don't like
that it's open okay moving on yeah
elevator yeah sure elevator speed me
into the first boss fight but that's I
said I'd rather face the boss that deal
with the tyrant again my god this is
never-ending nightmare of nightmare of
what are these goddamn fire hydrants for
there's got to be a reason that there's
fire hydrants here there's gotta be I
never did go down farther first but I
think it's still locked isn't it unless
oh my god I need to go get that stars
thing but oh my god you can just go get
it I didn't know you could just go get
it if I didn't know you would just go
get it I would've gone go get it I would
have gone got it
it wouldn't have been go kid it would
have been gone got that's fine all right
I didn't know that you could go straight
to that now I know now I know I don't
know what it's gonna be but it's gonna
be some cool improvement and I'm gonna
be so happy about it I'm gonna be so
happy I'll be so happy that I get this
improvement and people stop giving me
heart attacks that is what I'm hoping
for right now at this juncture what have
we here use that and it looks fun
it's a silencer is it oh no liquors
gonna hear me shooting up a storm Wow
I am happy about that okay can't go
there but I didn't want to go there
anyway okay that is good but I need much
more storage than what I have right now
but that's okay because I'm about to go
Li Lian
Leon Leon I feel like it's your job to
fight these bosses not me not my job
it's gonna be fine I doesn't make a lot
of sense but oh I'm not strong enough
oh okay I feel like this is rewriting
history but I guess history hasn't
happened yet yeah well I don't know
about the whole kidding you thing but it
seems to be happening so I'm gonna try
my flame rounds but I'm gonna try to
also get my [ __ ] I know there's a lot of
goodies waiting for me oh goody yes good
yes good heed I don't need that yet I'm
gonna just hope I don't need that hi how
are you doing okay okay listen you're
being a bit you're being a bit skidooed
Lee oh no yeah it's got to go down in
dd-do I'm 100% on board with that we're
yet I can't help you I cannot help you
the only thing I can do to help you is a
grenade in the face
you like that yeah oh you look good
oh you look healthy okay oh god oh god
oh god it's just nothing the grenades
they do nothing the grenades they do
nothing
how about some good old-fashioned
bullets yeah what are you doing over
there did that do anything
Oh God
REE you okay man
Oh where'd you go I should be safe right
here there's no way that it could got me
I feel I've got all my corners that
doesn't make any sense
all right can you just keel over and die
already I really greatly appreciate it
oh there we go ho easy as that
apparently my heart Berg okay bye
see you see you for round two yeah well
pretty badass you that's pretty good
Oh little girl you think you could toss
down that ladder racer
yeah of course
okay all right deals on I'm glad let me
go hey ah I gotta go get a bunch of
[ __ ] there's a lot of herbs I'm very
into herbage miss I like horticulture
and stuff and such as like is that oh it
didn't get these nah yep and I do not
have space for any of that hmm I guess I
could blend these then I just got that I
think there's still one more herb around
here somewhere yeah it looks like I'm
not gonna be able oh I guess I could
replace that cuz that's this bupkis now
I'm pretty sure anyway I think that's
the lesson that I learned from this okay
good enough all right kid I'm on the way
thanks for your patience I definitely
didn't abandon you and I probably got
some abandonment issues given that
everybody's dying around you and you
don't know what your parents are and I
kind of just killed your dad I think
that's your dad that way what about this
way what about looking in the lockers
kid you you you've got some things to
learn about perusing the lockers and
such as the like as that no [ __ ] yeah
well goddamn it
alright well combine that double green
love it gotta love it
gotta love it baby I can't fit this in
my inventory
I don't know where to put this oh [ __ ]
okay well I guess I'll never come back
here ever again so that's just gunpowder
lost oh well who needs it
hurry up kid you snooze you lose maybe
my dust nerd I'm gonna pull this lever I
don't care if you were gonna tell me to
do that Oh
Oh kid you are some kind of stupid if
you couldn't figure out that that lever
did that also can I say I look like Zoey
from left for dead
I think I know who did mom is hell yeah
yeah anyway thanks for bringing up my
harsh memories a really appreciated kid
yeah thanks a lot yeah way to go I'm
gonna go back and get that gunpowder and
then I'm just gonna horde up a bunch of
gunpowder and never use it because
that's how I like to play this game I
don't know it's like really high
strategies it's like top level plays
keeping all your gunpowder in its
gunpowder form so that it's more of a
more of like an encouraging thing it
makes you feel good instead of actually
using it for guns because if you
actually used it for your bullets then I
mean what are you a big baby what's that
gonna do for you nothing so I like to
keep it in its pure form because it
makes me feel pure and then I put it in
a line and I snort it and it really
gives me this nice rush I feel like
that's the best way to use gunpowder
period Dan save a there we go all right
good job me I'm way to go I'm very proud
of myself all right so let me put this
away and then put this here and I could
use more space but I don't have more
space so this is just what we got to
deal with hey kid come up to the parking
lot you're gonna love it
it's parking lot full of dogs you like
dogs right kid you like dogs I bet you
like dogs
you think eight is still gonna be here I
don't know if it is still gonna be here
how about you you know what's weird it's
like we've got the tyrant way sooner
than we had it ever before and I think
that's gotta just be because they're
[ __ ] with me
they gotta be right there gotta be just
be bigger with me I know I know when I'm
being dict with now I'm being dick with
early here oh really over there really
kid wanted to let me charge the
directions go somewhere
oh no it's closed is it is the closed
kid closed really why don't you get up
closer check yeah whatever
need a card apparently yeah real smart
move there Claire
okay then you tie her up now
or she dies
I don't like this guy some about this
guy don't rub me right
what's your name
what's your [ __ ] hand Claire sherry
come with me now say goodbye to my mom
absolutely
I think that guy was probably that girls
regard Ian and very responsible and
nothing bad is gonna happen period so I
should just probably not worry about
that he's got a gun but everybody has a
gun in this universe good to know this
okay that guy's an [ __ ] okay key card
first and then I'm gonna really probably
shoot him in his dick repeatedly over
and over and over again and then shoot
him a few more times just for good
measure
anyway this store wasn't open before
where does this go Hey yeah where did he
come from
no look map oh wow cool alright hello hi
Dimond I don't have a diamond but I know
where the diamond is
I do Oh chief irons ah oh then she's in
good hands
definitely definitely good hands press
elevator to chief's office now for
general use right
alright well I know where to go for the
diamond which means that I can get into
there and then go into the elevator and
then something something something I
have a plan okay hello anybody here hey
a blocks I like boxes quitman disposal
oh that's right this is the thing but
that and the thing look at the thing
open the thing I know what's in the
thing it's a thing oh Boesky it's a
thing okay whatever but there's
something else probably here mr. raccoon
that's a diamond thing who is in here
wasn't there oh yeah that's right there
are people here probably fine
it's fine I need to shoot that don't
wake up snooze you lose so all's good in
this neighborhood I just need to go to
the morgue
wherever the morgue may be I don't
remember where the morgue was it might
have been through the Ken
I just need to go to the morgue and get
myself what I need which is this way I
think oh no no no no you're fine if I
don't make any noise I've got a silenced
gun here for you
oh no oh hey oh oh oh I don't know if
I'm happy about that
that no that don't feel right that don't
feel right I feel bad I mean there were
horrible zombie dogs that we're gonna
chew my face off but hmm no no no no oh
no it's fine I'm fine
it's all fine it's all fine hello how
are you good me too
i nee nee meeny miney mo catch a tiger
by the toe hi now we've been through
this before
die you son of a [ __ ] oh you don't even
have it do y'all you do have it okay
well no not that one no I need to go
okay well how about we do this okay
really okay that was not worth it okay
note to self not worth some machine gun
ammo on a normal zombie literally use
anything but that don't hey dude
nope no no come on what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me I'm [ __ ] off
huh I'm gonna worry about what else is
later in here later I'm not gonna worry
about it now it's not my business now
what is my business is getting out of
your life you are in my way
your fat ass is in my way I don't think
I can sneak by you you gross don't
scratch your back alright if I were to
deal with this the way I'd like to deal
with this I would shoot you full of this
and then followed up with some of this
you didn't know where it came from
I'm still gonna kill you alright god I'm
good that does some good they don't even
know where it comes from because the
explosion is distant from where I is
alright but I got what I needed to get
so I'm just gonna go for it I'm gonna be
slow now uh yeah I'll be fine I'll come
back for that I know there's a lot of
goop in the morgue ah why was why you
dude you will not kill me you will not I
don't have any health but you are gonna
get a face full of this and then a
follow-up this nah that's right you just
fall over and die there you go that's
right yeah that's right I do not have
any health I don't know why I don't have
any health but I don't have anything
else but that's okay cuz I don't need
health cuz I'm gonna get whatever is in
this trunk and that's better than health
better than health better than health
OOP great
what is this JMB hp3 I don't tell me
what you mean to me I don't know what
that means what is that first to use
double stack magazines it was a marvel
firepower at the time due to how many
rounds it could hold okay so what about
that it's got a laser sight too that's
kind of cool I'm gonna die well before I
die let me see if I can get up to the
chief's office and maybe that is going
to be like up like a haven for
disgusting [ __ ] and you know that
that'll be something that I can see
before I die hello hi how are you hey
good to see you
Oh shoulder stock for what Oh neato more
stable trajectory I mean I don't really
care about the stable trajectory I do
fine without it if it doesn't give it
more damage I'm not really worried about
it
well feeling woozy alright good thing
this Chiefs got a private elevator it
leads down really nice good for him very
proud he worked hard for this probably
could I eat this straight I can't even
put it in my inventory I can drop this
okay discard that yeah burst peppers let
me see if there's like a like a safety
in here
Oh though it is it is let me read this
copy of email as thanks for your
unwavering support I've deposited a
small sum in your account to use as you
see fit
right get rid of them if you Madai ran
into some trouble with umbrella
headquarters the suits want to take the
fruit of my research away but don't
worry this will blow over soon
WB you are up to the security around my
lab your muscle desert to shoot any
suspicious persons on sight doesn't
matter if they kill them or even if
they're on Braille end points I'm so
close no [ __ ] getting in my way your
[ __ ] together to do your [ __ ] job I
told you any more security in the sewers
don't you know how critical it is it's
with money I can pay you whatever once I
take over but not before why don't you
get that never forget how expendable you
are it's not something not something you
want to say um let me get myself sorted
here I think I have mixed herb I only
need the only need the greens
I got plenty of green I could I don't
need to a full dugald anger put this in
combined with that bada-bing bada-boom
I'm in real danger use this up I feel
good and I'm done so that is all the
time I have for this episode of Resident
Evil 2 thank you everybody so much for
watching I've now fully transitioned
over to Claire and everything is going
so butter smooth I've got the hiccups
but don't mind that everything is going
so incredibly smooth I can hardly
believe it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]